this is the test
all right happy friday almost saturday
so being an adult is harder than it
looks take it from me and i'm someone
with the heart of a child which i keep
in the glove compartment
yeah uncomfortable laughter that's my
middle name he's pretty comfortable with
it
according to a new survey of 2 000
recent grads
81 of them wish they were taught more
life skills before graduating
apparently demanding an end to
misgendering non-binary students in the
geology department
wasn't enough prep on how to pay bills
without selling your kidneys
on craigslist list that was a long
sentence
the top skill these young people wish
they knew more about
include how to invest as well as
long-term financial planning
which is weird since who needs long-term
anything if the world's going to end in
eight years
if aoc's correct you might as well just
take up smoking
crack or meth crack and meth
other concerns are home maintenance like
resetting a wi-fi
router doing laundry and perhaps the
most important skill of all
unclogging a toilet sorry but what's to
learn about
unclogging a toilet first stop flushing
things that aren't toilet paper emily
oh god
blame it on whoever you're living with i
learned that from kill mead
but this but what this tells you is that
these little faberge eggs have never
heard of a plunger
when i grew up the only household tools
we used were the plunger
and the can opener and god forbid you
mix them up
something tells me though that if you
handed a plunger to a recent grad they
would attach a blm
sign to the end of the handle and wear
it like a rubber skull cap to an
anti-cop rally
it's a good look other findings were
three in ten regret not learning how to
budget
which makes them lousy grown-ups but
amazing politicians
one in five still don't know how to cook
unless it's thawing a hot pocket with a
blowtorch
the same number can't do their own
laundry which is
mind-blowing how hard is it really
to do your laundry just take a shower
with your clothes on
it's what ducey does every morning and
you get up that early
their top financial stress is paying
their monthly rent
which is normal we all worry about
paying bills when we're young
but that's why stripping was invented
[Laughter]
how do you think i could afford my gym
dues shaking these hips
so why all the regret about lacking real
life skills
because now they're in real life and
college had indulged a juvenile fantasy
world
much like cnn and they charged you a
fortune to tell you the skills
that made their parents successful
enough to afford tuition are for evil
people with dirty hands and dirty minds
and god forbid
american flags it's far better to
condemn capitalism than admit you
benefited from it
so what's the number one skill in life
that you should have you should have
learned
in my opinion it's to be useful it's
that simple
it overrides education and wealth if
you're useful you're indispensable
it's the opposite of the academics
definition of help
that fake activist theater that college
hammers into you
they believe help is you marching for
change or
holding a sign kneeling during the
anthem burning down a city block
dying your hair blue screeching at cops
who make less than your yoga instructor
now that isn't being useful that's the
phony college definition of
importance inflating your own ego making
yourself the center of attention
and what kind of clueless narcissists
act like that
[Laughter]
it's no life skill you know what it is
what is a life skill
dialing conflict down instead of up
that's useful
as two parent households dwindle god is
the example set by parents
to responsibly control your impulses and
anger
when conflict arises the skill of dying
dialing it down is lost and what's
filled that hole
the worst thing you could imagine the
mob and i'm not talking about the mafia
they had much better food
i mean the gawking hordes of social
media who prefer you dial things
up and not down so we have a generation
egged on by likes and clicks
who when they see something bad
happening instead of helping
turn into scorsese with a smartphone as
college deprives you of life skills the
only thing
left that you can grasp is this
exhibition activism
have you ever imagined the life of an
activist
do they a modern activist do they ever
enjoy a leisurely dinner
no do they have a comfortable group of
friends that they can bowl with
no could they help you out in a clutch
no
holy crap i think i described me
but they don't have jobs or a car or
even wisdom
could they be in a relationship with
anyone beyond a therapist or the amazon
delivery guy
could they get married no who would
agree to that
where would you honeymoon the chas in
seattle
you get hit by a fish at the market then
punched by a goon in the streets
but even more they have no life skills
just resentment student debt and hate
that again maybe they don't need life
skills because they don't have lives
the elite activist class prefers it that
way if these suckers ever wise up the
radical left his grip
is dead and woke ends up with a wake but
a cat
academia knows that if you can't survive
in real life
you'll cling to their bitter offerings
you won't be able to clog a toilet
because you're just too full
[Applause]
welcome tonight's goose
[Applause]
the national oh look at that
the national guard gets aroused when
they call up his unit
fox and friends co-host pete exit
[Applause]
the only time he gets laughs is from
asking women to dance
comedian joe mackey yeah
when she talks ben shapiro tells her to
slow down
outnumbered co-host emily capano
and finally he's so huge we use his
socks as parachutes
my massive sidekick and joseph nuff said
on fox nation tyrus
i'm glad we put acid in the water for
the audience
yeah you can tell so pete um you are you
have 30 what 33 children
33 yep at last count i asked him how
many nannies it takes you have what four
nannies on call
when necessary yeah yes brazilian mafia
actually that we have
uh in our neighborhood they're willing
to help out anything all right what do
you consider useful life skills
that would that would you you'd like to
see your kids learn
it's actually in preparing for this
segment i thought about when
i have to stop doing things for my kids
and when i need to start
making them do them excellent it's not a
it's not a clear line some kids are
ready for it earlier
but that is the responsibility of
parents and then in very in some places
i remember i took a homec
class in junior high and i learned how
to write a check that was nice i should
have taken shop class because i can't
i could we could throw an engine in
front of me and i have no idea what to
do with it i still regret not doing that
oh my god we've got joe mackey here yeah
he's on it
yeah any guy whose jacket stays zipped
up he knows stuff yeah yeah yeah
he's like night ride he's like night
rider without the car yeah
where's your talking car joe i don't
need a talking car greg i have my phone
for that
so more about your kids yeah so you're
saying like it's better to like almost
free range them
like throw them out there yeah at some
point you just got to let them go like i
make pancakes for them
you know in the next year or so it's
gotta be like you figure it out make it
for me i'll tolerate the mess
because turn them into little slaves
well that's what they are now free labor
eventually
we're not quite there yet not what
they're for greg what's gonna happen
when i'm old
i'm not gonna have any people changing
my diaper you can pay my kids oh there
you go
that's your option but then they go to a
safe space in a bubble where they get an
intersectionality degree and they've
never done their laundry
yeah but now i know why the antifa riots
they smell so poorly because there's no
laundry being done
exactly exactly time-tested thing yeah
you know tyrus you're the other person
here with children
allegedly yes a large family um courts
say so so sure
what would happen
is there any danger that your children
could end up as woke activists
no not at all because uh i believe in
the sea turtle parenting
uh theory critical sea turtle theory
you hatch from the egg you pull yourself
up from the sand well good luck
and there you go this is the fault
or the guilt of parents who work
hard and they feel guilty because they
got to work that 45
hour shift or the 50-hour shift so they
try to protect they want to do
everything for their kids so they feel
like they're making up for lost time
but what you're making is a spoiled brat
and they victim
who then learns how to manipulate whose
favorite thing to do is
ma you do it i'm playing the game ma i
don't want to do it
the ones who complained who said that
they never learned life skills
no you were taught you just chose not to
pay attention
because you're in your phone or in your
game or whatever it was that you want to
do at that time
and you learn now to play the victim
like oh gee i really wish i knew i
learned
my mom would have taught me to learn how
to do laundry she did
you just didn't want to do it you threw
a tantrum and she did it for you
how hard is it to learn laundry you know
because here's the deal
my mother worked hard but she didn't
feel guilt
she was pissed she had to work hard and
couldn't go party so
if my clothes had stained on it well you
your big ass put it there there's the
machine figure it out you can read right
yeah you go to school five days a week
right so you had to learn something
there there this is ty good luck
and at first you're like well and then
you figure it out because you don't want
to be made fun of at school
there needs to be you need to let them
fail i call it life lessons
daughter's climbing a chair her mom be
like help her nope life lesson coming up
[Laughter]
next time she sees that chair she's
gonna i don't know
life lesson you know as a kid in the 70s
i had that amazing
combination of motherhood and alcohol
like that moms
moms were great moms combination yeah
that works
they would like by noon they would have
their lunch drink and then but they
would be
they the food would get a little bit
more sloppy right like you might find a
cigarette
and then ravioli yeah but you know it
was
mom was pretty fun by six o'clock joe
how you doing
i'm hanging in there greg yeah that's
all we can ask for with you are you cold
no it's freezing in here there's like
icicles coming down here
what did you learn from this research
this survey what disturbed you what
excited you
what confused you i didn't learn
anything i didn't already know because i
remember my
uh guidance counselor in college asked
me what i wanted out of college
and i said i wanted a college degree
and he got kind of mad and said well
what are you going to do with that
i'm like did you go to college to be a
guidance counselor
the whole idea is preposterous and i
ended up coming to new york and getting
a temp job in human resources
yes where a lot of the other temps were
high school grads
that just got a temp job and they were
getting paid by the company
to go to college to get a degree in the
job
they were already doing none of it makes
any sense
college is for most degrees a piece of
paper that doesn't really teach you
anything you need it just said
hey i jump through that hoop right so if
you're looking for college to get
life skills that's why they don't call
it the real world right you're in the
whole
wrong place to get that it is a college
degrees are the original uh virtue
signal they are due to corporations
because like and so now if you oh now
you got to get a graduate
degree now you got to get a phd and your
debt just keeps increasing
but it's like it's like an arms race
between over-educated over-caffeinated
people
let's go to elvira how you doing
it's funny because it didn't happen to
me
[Laughter]
i'm just talking about that you look
stunning in your black dress
thanks yeah you know what's interesting
about college students the people with
the least amount of wisdom
are the ones that are shouting at us
that's the thing that just drives me
crazy
i wouldn't mind them admitting that they
don't have life skills
if they also admitted don't tell us
about what's wrong with this world but
it's me they've married this
ignorance of life skills with this
arrogant belief that they can yell at us
i don't know
absolutely that's always how it is right
it's the smallest dog that does the
loudest barking
oh is that an attack at me
subconsciously um you're absolutely
right and to
your point i totally agree i think the
issue for these kids starting at a young
age is either being enabled
or one or an issue of exposure so either
parents in the home or whatever home
life they have has enabled the fact that
they don't know how to do anything
or they won't they weren't exposed to it
and they had a different kind of home
and they weren't exposed to it
in the school systems which is why
school choice should come in and having
other types of exposures i mean think
about what our schools are focusing on
right
make sure you have the right pronoun
make sure you understand this right and
this is how this is oppressive and this
is how this should be and all these
boxes that have to be checked
but along the way they're probably
missing the kids that don't know how to
do laundry and don't even
don't wash their own clothes or whatever
they're seeing a whole other ton of
fundamental issues
and it goes up through graduate schools
i learned more in my first hearing
than i did in my entire criminal law
class i learned more in one hour
in a prison that i did in all years of
law school which is why i think
visiting prison which is why i think
that all right
i saw your expressions i saw your
expressions did she just say she was in
the pin
which is why i think every judge every
attorney also every politician
they should all spend spend one ride on
the subway spend one hour
in the prison like the it it takes a
lifetime of these
concepts you learn in schools to amount
to one minute in the real world and i
think the world would be a whole
different place if these guys that make
decisions for the rest of us would have
some of that real world experience so
basically what you're saying is people
who have experience in wisdom should be
exposing themselves to children
that's a felony yeah oh yeah you
dropped the one on that one little dog
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else